assalamualaikum guys hope you guys are
doing well welcome to my channel today i
saw a very disturbing video of a very
disturbed individual
i knew he was disturbed but i did not
know he was disturbed to this level this
is an individual called tommy robinson
by the way you guys might know
uh with somebody that's totally avoiding
me and my team absolutely he's too busy
going and picking on people that are
uneducated don't know about their
religion
and people that can't speak english
properly you guys all know what happened
is
grenfell towers i want you guys to
imagine this and i'm gonna put this
image
up front so you guys understand where
i'm coming from and why i'm
so upset um imagine seeing this
this building is on fire it's burning
and there's people in there throwing
their babies out
jumping out and most of them burnt to
death
right these events were so horrific so
horrific
and due to lack of safety measures
hundreds of people have lost their life
no sprinklers
no safety measures all that was done was
money that was spent
on the outer look so it looks appealing
so the rich people around the
area could see something pleasing to
their eye you know because that's what
matters
now looking at that obviously a lot of
us feel disturbed
uh and we feel upset this issue is so
disturbing that a recent study
uh done uh showed that people who
actually
witnessed this event happening were
suicidal
they had psychological issues they were
going through
now this is how much people were
affected and
rightly so now if i said to you guys
hold on a second
let's talk about an individual who did a
video today
and let alone on the day when the fire
was happening
let alone the weeks after that not a
single help
nothing he did not even come there this
is the same individual who runs
when he hears a muslim carrying out a
terrorist attack this guy runs
and i do not blame him for that it's
about selective
outrage though that's my problem after
seeing this tragic event happening
who on earth in their right mind will
say what um what this guy is about to
say
let's watch for ourselves i also see
from a human side and from a father
as children burned as children died so
that's why
saying anything negative about this is
well not what people want to do i didn't
really want to do it so i'm stuck on
should i do this shouldn't i do this
no you uh [ __ ] you should have not done
this if you had an
atom weight of brain cell in your head
you would never talk
negatively about this let's look at what
he says next guys
sorry but no illegal immigrants are
exactly that they're illegal
god knows how many were in that tower
how the authority's been ignoring this
for so long
why when london so overcrowded the
benefit systems buckling
how's it so difficult to find our
capital city why are we tolerating
illegal immigrants squatting
can you imagine this this guy is more
concerned
about immigrants in that building rather
than these immigrants losing their life
he's more concerned about why
were they there why were they there then
being more concerned about them losing
their life this is absolute
madness like this guy is an absolute
extremist
hate preacher look at his priorities now
you think that is bad
right look at what he says next this is
very disturbing guys
and this should not go unanswered we
should not let tommy robinson get away
with this rubbish
and here's another one why is it that
the residents of gwen grenfell deserve
to be given luxurious cancer and
properties in compensation
like can you imagine he's more concerned
about the victim families compensation
like can you imagine if you went to the
victim families do you really think they
give a
damn about oh where am i gonna oh yes
though so that's great i'm gonna live in
this amazing
nice kensington house they don't give a
damn
about where they're gonna live they've
lost family members you bloody how low
can you be
and you're here and you're here moaning
and crying
because they are compensated a luxury
house
for the lives that they've lost let's
carry on
listen it's a tragedy it's an accident
and i'm not saying please
please please save your rubbish please
save your rubbish
you know your stop acting this is
nothing but an
absolute act just to suit your agenda
look at the filth that's coming out of
your mouth maybe we shouldn't work to
help those people find new homes
i'm not saying we shouldn't help this
will find new homes it's just i have a
problem with the
kind of homes you want to put them in
how [ __ ] can you be can you imagine
something
i don't have a problem with housing them
i have a problem with what kind of house
you give them
but hang over properties that people
would pay hundreds of thousands if not
millions
for to people receiving welfare well
that makes no sense at all look at this
look how cheap
human life is and let me tell you
something it's not about human life this
guy
because he knows a lot of muslims live
there and he has
nothing he says nothing about the work
the muslims did on that day
how many lives they saved nothing he
doesn't want to know and hear about it
all he's concerned about is these
immigrants
living in nice houses after what they've
been through
he's more concerned about that guys
let's not forget that why should people
have to work their whole entire life to
afford a kensington home
only for someone who's been in the
country five minutes to be moved in next
door for free
i'm sorry i'm not having it neither
should you can you imagine this somebody
who's worked the entire life
to own this house let's compare that
with somebody who's lost their family
members who have
burnt to death are they the same no you
[ __ ] they're not the same
that these individuals lost their family
members
deserve that house more than somebody
who's
worked to have a luxury life absolute
madness this guy has lost his
mind the main question though the one we
have to ask
just how many people died in that tower
block i
hate to have to talk about something so
sensitive but it's important to consider
the facts
oh please cut the rubbish please cut the
rubbish and you know what he wants to
know how many people died in that block
look police and politicians don't want
us to know about that gap
because they'd have to admit the illegal
immigration problem is much bigger than
they want you to think it is
there are reports that as many as 42
bodies were found in just one apartment
so do you know what he's trying to
insinuate he's trying to insinuate that
there were sublettings which he has no
evidence for
and he's saying there was 42 people
around in one room
now to his mentality he's thinking 42
people in one room
evidence for subletting so there was 42
people living there how about you
[ __ ] maybe there was a fire people were
scared
they gathered into one room thinking
they'll be safe and they won't die
no oh yeah no no of course not that's
the agenda
42 people living in a subletted house
yes perfect
absolutely vile absolutely disgusting
but why is this even on the news still
well i think we know the answer don't we
it's a convenient way of distracting the
masses
every day we hear about grandfather you
imagine he has a problem
with hearing the grenfell tragedy he has
a problem with that
he has a problem with hearing that
tragic event
that took place he has a problem with
that and you know why meanwhile islamic
attacks are still occurring all over
europe
every day look at that how he had to
bring islam into that
i would not blame this guy if he ordered
a pizza
and they brought the wrong bloody pizza
and he would blame islam and quran for
that
can you imagine guys and this guy who
doesn't even know nothing about islam
writing a book about the quran
it's like hitler writing a book on the
old testament and here he is blaming
these immigrants why are these
immigrants here in the first place
you america the biggest terrorists
because of foreign policy
we go into their country our government
america
bomb them kill a million people in iraq
half a million afghanistan
blow their whole country apart and when
they come here oh
why did you have to come here go back
you know
we've come to your country invaded stole
the oil but why are you coming here
let's look at the root of the problem
it's a foreign policy that's causing
all this mess and we've got a [ __ ] like
you who is there talking about oh
this uh this happened because of that oh
it's because of the quran
all your rubbish yeah all your nonsense
you're an absolute coward
if you was a man enough you would not
run away from me and my team
and face us because we will expose you
and give you
your intellectual burial fgm fgm is
happening across our country every day
thousands of migrants are pouring into
our continent every day we're more
interested in spending our time talking
about grenfell
remember the westminster bridge attack
how long did it take the media to shut
up about that
two three days london bridge attack
manchester attack
i've never seen a coverage on the same
scale as grenfell for any of these
tragedies
what about all the thousands of people
have been killed by drone airstrikes
what about them what about the milli
about a million people wiped from the
face of this earth
one million people terrorism is
terrorism no matter
who does it we have a problem with all
terrorists
we have a problem with all grooming
gangs we have a problem with all those
people commit rape
you have only a problem with those
who are only muslims committing these
acts and that's disgusting
guys i want you to hashtag the following
thing at the bottom
don't let this viral animal get away
with this make
sure everybody sees this and it's this
guy's real face
and soon tommy i know you're watching
this we're going to meet you soon
guys till next time assalamu alaikum do
share this
with your friends and family i urge you
guys please please please share this